I don't want to calculate
high-resolution utopia for myself only
to have it squandered by fortune how do
I ensure the meaning I experience is
self determined well you can't because
there's an arbitrary element to
existence so it is going to be
squandered to some degree by fortune but
that's that's not the point what are you
gonna do just sit back on your laurels
and wait for things to roll over you so
what you do look the Hellmuth basically
says go out there confront the drag and
get the gold share it with the community
and and and live properly or it says the
alternative is face the tyrant enter the
desert as a consequence because
everything falls apart recast structure
find the promised land those are the two
elements to the hero myth and you mites
and that's divine it's the closest thing
to divine that we know you might say
well what happens if you follow the
divine path and the answer might be well
everything turns out perfectly because
God is on your side it's like no that
isn't what happens because things don't
turn out perfectly it's your best bet
it's your best strategy right that's the
thing and you know dragons wouldn't be
dragons if they couldn't eat you and so
but that's okay that's okay and this is
something I found so useful about the
biblical stories especially about the
Abrahamic stories which I didn't know
that well till I lectured about them
last year you know God calls people to
the adventure of their lives and so you
could say in part God is that force
within you which calls you to the
adventure of your life and says get away
from your family get away from your
blind and unconscious comfort and get
the hell out there in the world well God
calls Abraham out from his father's
where he stayed far too long and from
his kin where it's secure and like the
first thing he encounters is a famine
and then he encounters a tyranny
inhabited by people who want to steal
his wife it's like you think well okay
Abraham should have just stayed in bed
and ignored God obviously well that
isn't how it is it's like we're built
for struggle as human beings you know
you're not after the bubbles of bliss
that Dostoyevsky described in in notes
from underground
we're built to contend with the world
we're
built to contend with reality you want a
challenge and the best way that you can
take on a challenge because the
challenge fortifies you so you don't
want to be secure you want to be strong
and you get strong by taking on optimal
challenges and so you lay out your
destiny in the world and you take the
slings and arrows of fate and you make
yourself stronger while you're doing so
and you might fail and fortune might do
you in but it's your best bet and you
know people have also people that have
extracted unbelievable successes out of
catastrophic failures and so and I'm not
saying that in a naive way I know
perfectly well what happens to people
you know you're doing fine in life and
then you get cancer and then six months
later you're dead and all the heroism in
the world isn't going to save you at
that point but that's not the point
that's not the point
life is bounded by mortality but that
doesn't mean that you don't get out
there and contend and you develop by
contending and you minimize the net
amount of suffering in the world and
that's something man that's something to
do so it's it's it beats laying in your
basement and getting bitter and then
doing the terrible things that bitter
people do so you can't ensure that the
meaning you experience is self
determined but you can play your role to
the best of your ability and that will
be good enough and that will be good
enough that meaning the meaning that
you'll find in then in that I believe is
sufficient to be sustaining and perhaps
even sustaining through the flood so it
isn't that you can avoid catastrophe
it's that you can prepare yourself to
deal with it honorably when it arrives
that's what you've got